[Music]
it's the matinee show once again
yeah good movies this week this was a
really good week it's like one of the
best weeks that I've been remember like
you know what I mean we said when we see
good movies every week but this week it
just seemed like it was pretty much all
good yeah let's get Creepshow out of the
way
yeah so the first thing we're gonna talk
about as we usually do is the latest
episode of creep show yeah the Shutter
original series now this was actually
the last episode of the first season
they only had six because I guess they
just wanted to see like how it was gonna
do and stuff like that was kind of like
a pilot season thankfully it did so well
like I said it broke all kind of records
on shuttered like have you know number
of people streaming new people signing
up with stuff like that so it actually
has been green-lighted for a second
season yeah hopefully it'll be better
actually than this one yes so um you
know so we'll see like it probably I
would imagine that the second season
will probably have more episodes
depending in maybe they'll have like a
higher budget and [ __ ] like that
yeah and for a pilot season this is this
is a pretty good pilot it was it's like
usually bad a lot of times policies I
mean it was uneven like obviously but
it's an anthology that hundred and
that's to be expected it's like not
everything can be like the original
Creepshow movie or like every single
story was good it's like everything yeah
it's like pretty much every other
anthology I've seen has always got like
one or two really good stories and then
others that are just like meh you know
what I mean yeah and you get the same
thing here but like I said you know
kudos to everybody involved they
actually like pulled this off and you
know got it all off the ground and I'm
really glad ya got renewed for a second
season and I'm like really looking
forward to it one of the one of my
friends on Tom [ __ ] shitty movies on
Face best my facebook group Tom Tom
shitty movies with two DS he thought
that the movie thought he didn't like it
that much the whole season this is the
series
yeah the series they said it was kind of
like something made-for-tv I kind of
have to disagree I mean if you go back
and look at the old Tales from the Crypt
TV series yes I thought for the most
part the writing was good
production values were very low on that
this is a lot better yeah it's like they
only have so much money you know I mean
and it's like you know this was you
it's a pretty ambitious project it's on
par with a Netflix series oh yeah and
it's easily better than a lot of menus
that I've seen yeah the motif is like
the original nut Creepshow you know what
the animated sequence is in between and
I liked it now in this particular one
the first story was a lot better than
the second story yeah I would agree with
you on that one first story was about
this company that's getting it's like a
cosmetic surgery time yeah first it's
called skin crawlers is the it's the
name of the yes story and they have kind
of like this replacement for liposuction
they're gonna put this down fluke
in you that they found in the end on the
outside then it drinks all your fat away
well that [ __ ] doesn't turn out good you
know it is psycho was about Nessie right
well a Nessie like Nessie like who was
it called it's the it's called champion
which champey she's like a real it's a
real thing it's like an example I mean
it's not a real thing but it's like a
real legend it's real legend that
there's like an SEO like creature living
in Lake Champlain yeah and this one I
just kind of couldn't hold my attention
yeah a lot about yeah I was gonna say so
okay so going back to the first one
which was actually directed by Roxanne
Benjamin she also directed the the Lydia
lanes better half won the one about the
you know the two women in the elevator
so she directed this first one as well
like I said the story was called skin
crawlers and yeah it had to do with it
made me laugh because like the main guy
in this was played by Dana Gould who I
remembered because like I said I used to
watch like it's a lot of stand-up and
[ __ ] like that on Comedy Central like
back and then late 80s and early 90s and
it seemed like he was on a lot of stuff
like there was a lot of his stand-up and
everything like that and I was like wow
did they put a fat so you don't never
did you really get that fat mmm I mean
he's not like fat fat but he was like
pretty chummy so he was um so he's
looking to like lose weight and [ __ ]
like that and he hears about this
company called skin deep by Sloane and
the the you know sleek and perfect like
doctors like yeah they found this
[ __ ] eel /li
like a blood fluke or a fluke Werner
yeah or something like that yeah it's
kind of like big you know what I mean it
was kind of like an eel sized pretty
much yes big and um they're like yes so
basically this thing just eats fat and
it will make you like skinny and
beautiful like immediately yeah and I
was like how does that does it eat like
all your excess skin too because like
they don't really seem to talk about
that what do you do nothing that much
waited a couple attorneys out this [ __ ]
lays eggs in YouTube and I guess they
didn't know I don't know how I didn't
know they said they had human trials I
know what I thought well what what
[ __ ]
well know what ends up happening is that
they did have human trials but the
problem was that there was an eclipse
and there was like some kind of like
weird like magnetic anomaly or so and
that's what I don't even know if I don't
even know I can't remember if the Eels
like actually did lay eggs in there or
if they're like the Eclipse or like
something having to do with like the
climax the climatic you know this stuff
was like making the eels like bust out
of the bodies okay you know what I mean
so I guess they did lay eggs in there
there they stayed in there or something
like that I'll say no do you know I was
sitting there drinking tequila
yeah I'm just enjoying it I've liked it
I'm not trying to overanalyze [ __ ] right
just I know how this is gonna go bad
next thing I know they're four yeah so
the thing is it's like I guess I mean
the doctor I think he even explains it's
like you know we did do human trials on
this and it's totally safe and
everything like that but they didn't do
a human trial during an eclipse and I
guess it was like this particular thing
that happened during the Eclipse like
whatever the you know the magnetic field
of the earth yet have a second one go
but that was um but that was the first
ones like I said the first one uh you
know was super fun it was like a gory
Dana Gold's character was like great in
it is like this guy that you know he he
was like actually reluctant to like get
this [ __ ] done at first because as soon
as he finds out it's this big [ __ ]
eel that like sucks the feta he's like
yeah no thank you but then he gets
talked into it later on because he sees
this other woman that was there with him
in the waiting room and she was like
this big fat woman and then he sees her
like a day or two later and she looks
like perfect and then yeah so he's like
oh maybe you know maybe
we'll do that well [ __ ] you know yeah I
I can see how yeah most people would
probably do that if they said hey you
can like lose weight in like one day and
all you have to do is attach this leash
it'll suck your fat out I'd probably do
ya know what was the second one about
now the second one this was like for
some reason this one like kind of
disappointed me it's like the name of
the story was I think it was called by
the silver water of Lake Champlain this
is based on a short story by Joe Hill
and it was directed by Tom Savini of all
people so it's basically about that you
know there's a family and it's like a
mom and the dad has died and there's two
kids and kind of like a jackhole
stepfather as you have cuz you know
Stephen King and Joe Hill both have
those you know I mean Stephen King must
really like hated his dad or whatever or
but he has a lot of those types of
characters and Joe Hill does as well
so the dad has died looking for champey
you know this supposedly mythical
creature that lives in Lake Champlain
like I said just like the Loch Ness
monster
and you know everyone thought he was a
nutcase everything like that was a
little girl the daughter you know she
had faith you know that ciampi was
really there so she's like obsessed with
like going out of like looking forward
and [ __ ] like that so at the start of
the story
you kind of get you know they're saying
something about like these atmospheric
she keep saying these atmospheric
conditions us like this disease are just
like you know the atmospheric conditions
the last time that champion was seen
like many decades ago or whatever it was
so she gets like super excited about it
everyone's like pickin on her and [ __ ]
like that and as the story goes on um
you find out that I mean her and her
little boyfriend and her brother they go
and they find what they think is champy
like dead on the shore yeah she thinks
she's gonna vindicate her dad's work and
everything yeah which was one thing that
I thought was kind of messed up was that
she's like well I want my dad to get the
credit because he gave his life like
looking for this animal and everyone
thought he was a nut and everything like
that so I want him to get the credit for
finding it so the so the boyfriend has
the weird he's like well you know this
ciampi is dead so I'm just gonna carve
your dad's name like in the side of this
animal and then like with the date on it
which I thought was kind of
bizarre and then take a take a picture
of it with the cellphone which I don't
know I just thought that was really
weird um and then you know so inevitably
the [ __ ] stepfather comes out there
and it's like oh you know I'm gonna make
all this money and I'm just like
threatens to kill the boyfriend which
you know nice he's like a [ __ ]
teenager and [ __ ] like that so you know
as will probably be a surprise to no one
the champion that they find on the
shores of Lake Champlain is just the
baby champ II yeah and the mom comes and
eats I remember day yeah it wasn't much
to it really yeah it's like I the
special effects were good it was you
know and I said Twilight Zone levels it
was yeah it's like so like I said I was
kind of like hoping it would be better
because I loved Tom Savini I loved Joe
Hill it just felt like this story was a
little bit Finn it felt like it could
have been a lot shorter because I do
feel like I feel like they took too long
like established I'm like okay this
stepfather is an [ __ ] okay they look
for champion okay this net is it feels
like there was a lot of like repeated
dialogue and I think it was like I said
you know these things are only about 15
minutes long was very simple idea they
wanted somebody to get eat by champy
yeah so that's really what they wrote a
story about that yeah and I have a story
around that yeah it wasn't all that well
I haven't read the original story that
it was based on so there might have been
although it wasn't original yeah it was
did Joe Hill short story okay he didn't
write the teleplay but he wrote the
short story that was based on so you
know maybe there was a lot more in it
but I just felt like it was a little
repetitive
you know the creature effects were cool
it's like everybody likes to see that as
well stepfather getting eaten by a giant
like a Loch Ness monster that's that was
fun but other than that I just thought
it like it was cool the way it was shot
was cool it was like really foggy and
like atmospheric and everything and I
thought that was neat but other than
that it just didn't really grab me like
a lot of the characters didn't grab me I
didn't really you know what I mean it's
just one of the stories it's not you
know yeah it was fine it was just not
like what am i Santa didn't really stand
out that I don't think it was my least
favorite of the season but it was
probably like in the bottom I'm sure
it's hard to make all these little short
stories with so many series has been out
there you know I mean you're bound to
redo one of them well yeah there's like
so many ideas
I mean you might want to go back to it
the tails the [ __ ] series and pull
something out of there you know I mean
they there's only so many different
stories you could tell but anyway that
was the end of the first series and
hopefully the second series will be
better yeah I mean definitely and like I
said you know yeah it was hit or miss
and stuff like that but you know I
admire their [ __ ] spirit and getting
this back on there and getting and it
being so successful yeah um so I'm
really looking forward to the second
yeah season and we'll see how it comes
you
all right the second movie we saw this
week we actually saw in the theater this
was the Korean film parasite this is an
excellent movie I had been waiting to do
this for a long time een this came out
in Korea back in May and it's been out
in Europe for quite a while because it
was at the Cannes Film Festival it
actually won the Palme d'Or which is
like the highest thing and it won by
unanimous vote which is the first time
that that's happened for many years yeah
I think it's also I don't know if it's
this I guess it'll be next year but it's
like that South Korea's entry into the
foreign film like Academy Award yes so
we'll see how it goes and if it wins I
honestly I think it probably should win
even though I haven't seen a lot of
other horror foreign films this year
having lived in Korea in the early 90s
man I just I see these kind of movies
and as [ __ ] love them because I think
I can kind of relate to them I know the
culture and just see how much they've
kind of moved up in the world you know
them in like they actually have upper
classes now and it's like a class
Society yeah you know which they didn't
they had it back then but it just wasn't
so prevalent you know cuz Korea really
hadn't amassed the amount of wealth that
it has now compared to what it was when
I was there but it's fine cuz they're
having all these like class issues yeah
about you know between the working class
and and and rich people yeah and that's
really what this story's about it's
called parasite yeah the thing is is
that as you watch the movie who are the
parasites well it's a cool flick it's
about some poor people that live in a
shitty half basement apartments a whole
family of them a couple in their 50s
with their children it's a and they're
like early 20s late teens yeah and
they're like college age yeah and the
the boy gets recommended to become a
tutor to a rich family through a friend
that he has is going overseas his
friends in love with this girl yeah but
the daughter a dog family right who's
only high school sophomore really but
it's Korean culture you know I mean they
they go younger I guess anyway once he
makes his way in there to make a long
story short he and his family hatch this
this wacky did this bizarre and kind of
cruel plan to take over every servant
position in this damn house yeah the dad
they could try to weasel the dad in as a
driver and the mom in as the housekeeper
and the sister in as the art teacher and
that's just the beginning of the trouble
it's funny as hell it is it's it's it's
hard to tell if this is comedy or horror
it's both yes both I don't want to spoil
the end of it there's a lot more to this
story than meets the eye as you know I
thought I knew what the movie was about
until I got so I got about two-thirds
the way through it yeah and then that
last one third it kind of did a flip on
me yeah this is women this is what's
happened what the [ __ ] is this and
there's just a bunch of you know
existential stuff happening you know
about I don't know what's there's a lot
of different themes about who is worth
what and what's valuable and culture and
what's valuable in relationships and who
is a parasite are they living off this
rich family or is this rich family
living off of backs of the poor and yeah
it's like well that's what I mean is
this is easily one of the best movies
I've seen this year and it seems like
it's getting I mean what's like some of
the reviews I read of it afterward it
was always got like 99% like I'm wrong
yes that's audience and yeah it's great
it's really fantastic yeah obviously
it's it's directed by bong joon-ho who
also did memories of murder he also did
snowpiercer you know he did [ __ ] he
did all this like great like oak jaw he
does a he's the host obviously if you're
a horror fan like monster movies he did
that one as well
and I feel like this is something that
we were talking about this in the car on
the way back I feel like honestly one
some of the best movies that I've seen
in the last few years have been Korean
South Korean movies I saw the devil the
whaling train to Busan you know and
those are all different directors but
you know those are easily some of the
best movies
I've seen in the last few years
something that Korean film and maybe
Asian film in general seems to do really
well that American films really can't
seem to pull off is being sort of genre
less but I'm also pulling off a total
shift in the middle that doesn't feel
like a whiplash another thing is is that
there isn't any American contemporary
political agendas shoved in the movie
it's just the story and the story itself
has agendas but they're not really
American agendas they're Universal yeah
it's a universal thing that everyone can
relate to it's like you know it's a
class struggle right that's which
snowpiercer was as well at the same
director right um you know they've done
that here there would have been a
Republican Democrat dichotomy but that
isn't in this movie not really did not
know because the Koreans don't really
have that the way we have it and I was I
was trying to think like when I was
watching it because I went into this
movie knowing who the director was I had
seen a couple of his other I saw
memories a murder I saw the host I saw
some of his other movies and so I knew
sort of what I was getting into but I
deliberately didn't read anything I said
I don't really want to know it's about
or anything like that I just want to go
see it and just kind of let it unfold
and when I was coming I was like what
genre would you call this I don't even
know what genre you would call it it's
definitely it starts out as I get a
comedy may kinda like our comedy um but
and there's suspense and adventure in it
it's almost kind of like a heist movie
or like a scam type movie I always like
a bank heist a lot of sneaking around
and to say it is real funny you think
they're gonna get caught and they're
constantly on getting away with [ __ ]
just by the skin of their teeth and
there's some good plans that actually
come to fruition but then there's things
that they unforeseen stuff that comes
out of the blue it's just ya can't spoil
it you just gotta see it yourself it's
not yet and then it goes in like
directions that you probably don't act
in in a way even though I'm gonna say it
reminded me of another Korean movie the
whaling even though it in the way that
you know the whaling kind of started out
even though it had like
this grotesque like mass-murderer type
thing going on but it almost started out
as like this sort of like bumbling cop
comedy and then it just got more and
more horror this one um doesn't really
go in a horror direction exactly but
it's a similar kind of like tonal shift
yeah you know what I mean as the wailing
yeah you're not as out right horn yeah
you're we're also really unsure about
who the bad guys who the good guys are
yeah that's the interesting thing about
it I don't even know if there are any
because everyone everyone is relatable
everyone is relatable and sympathetic
and you sympathize with them but also
you question some of their decisions and
you've been like so it's like a really
nuanced yes way life is not everyone is
really good or purely bad but the cool
thing about it too is that it has like
kind of all these weighty themes and
[ __ ] like that like in all this you know
kind of subtext but it's also really fun
and like really entertaining yeah it's
not boring at all it's not like an art
flick or anything like that I mean like
I said there's a subtext you can take it
if you want it but it's still just a fun
watch it's an entertaining watch and
which i think is why it's getting so
many accolades because it really
balances the best of both worlds yeah
you know where it's like it has kind of
like this - message - it sort of but
it's also like a straight ride it's a
great ride like just to watch and you
can just enjoy it as a film and just
have a good time with it yeah you know
what I mean so I think that's really
cool one thing I wanted to say - because
you were talking about how cool the the
rich family are named are called the
parks they're cool their house well
Korean surname Park yeah it's probably
Parker camp
it's like Smith yeah yeah well in the
end the poor family I think their last
name was Kim yeah but so yeah that's why
I guess they wanted them to be like
generic so like I stand in for everyone
well there's only three say names are
Kim and crock yeah
yeah there's like a McQuack that's it
but no I was gonna say like I remember
you saying how much the you liked the
house that the park family lived in that
house was entirely built for the movie
yeah it's a real modern it wasn't like
that
they made it they did it specifically
because they wanted like particular
sunlight for yeah it's a modern oh it's
a modern Korean interpretation of a
Western house a lot of wood a lot of
concrete it's absolutely nothing
yeah look what it looked like something
from the 60s really but not really yeah
just like it was like I'm like almost
kind of cubist yeah yeah they're kind of
like Danish modern yeah like those neat
but yeah it was like really cool looking
but yeah and the cinematography and this
is like really really nice like the shot
walking and everything like that it's
like a really great looking movie but
yeah I definitely recommend this writing
and it's yet anybody and it wouldn't
surprise me if it got all kind of Oscars
because it's already got like [ __ ]
[ __ ] tons of other awards like from all
the festivals yet that have played at
like around the world because like I
said we it took us a while to get it
like yeah it's probably in the theaters
is the time that you're watching this
yeah it's limited release but it's it's
already made over a hundred million
dollars worldwide that's right keep it
into a lot of theaters so I imagine the
more that it gets there's a lot of
people in the audience oh we saw it they
were laughing yeah I liked it yeah we
actually had a lot of people in our
theater as well so I think that it'll
kind of like as word-of-mouth goes on
it'll probably like get a lot bigger
because it's already made a [ __ ] ton of
money and Korea Germany France
everything like that so but yeah
definitely definitely recommended it's
an awesome awesome movie
you
I read and the third movie we saw this
week we we've been looking forward to
this for a long time I love this dr.
sleeve I loved it it was really good
it's really good you know there's it's
getting good ratings pretty much
everywhere yeah some of the reviewers
you know like professional reviewers are
giving it like 76 on Rotten Tomatoes
some of the people are going well I
don't know I don't know do you guys like
it they're asking us if we like it you
know I mean they're reviewing the
[ __ ] thing yeah I thought it was an
excellent movie uh it's a worthy sequel
to The Shining if that's what you want
to call it it is a shame but it's really
more of a dap tation of the book that
was yea written it was kind of a sequel
to The Shining but you get to find out
what happens and Danny Torrance and what
happens to the Overlook but there's a
lot more to it than that Danny is dr.
sleep is like the nickname that Danny
got he was using the shine he was where
he was kind of a it's kind of a he was
the orderly at a hospice an orderly at a
hospice so he could use his shining to
kind of settle people down and have
visions with them as they died so to
help them cross over to the other side
yeah and then so the patients called him
dr. sleep because he he could comfort
you why you were dying but don't want
too many spoilers while he was doing
this he become he basically comes in
contact with a cult of evil people who
have the shining and they're committing
really horrible crimes related to the
shining this they have psychic abilities
and it's so bad that he's basically has
to come out of retirement and stop this
evil cult yeah and there's a little girl
involved too yeah he's also very very
powerful yeah she's about 15 I think
about 14 or 15 yeah I mean it takes
place over many years yes she's a little
kid when she first finds out what's
going on and sends in the message and
then I think eight years later they
eventually meet up and try to stop this
cult yeah and
you can pretty much tell from from the
trailers that they do have to go back to
the Overlook and I just they just did a
great job it's this is not a Kubrick
this is not a Kubrick movie but there
are a lot of callbacks of shoutouts to
Kubrick yeah there's a lot of Easter
eggs in it in a way oh yeah the the the
movie ties in carry the firestarter dead
zone and The Shining are all kinda
they're all kind of brought into the
same universe with this movie in terms
of the psychic abilities remember like
beam up with your mind from firestarter
and telekinesis and they didn't really
get into pyrokinesis but out-of-body
experiences and remote viewing all this
yeah this is like some call you Mian
type stuff it kind of took me back to my
mammoth mountain episode you know I mean
this is how I imagined some of this
stuff I've seen the other stuff I think
might be plausible but I haven't seen it
but you know this movie kind of puts it
all in the same universe I loved it yeah
I thought it was [ __ ] I was just I
was really interested to see how you
were gonna take this because I mean I
read the book and I read it like fairly
recently so it was like Freddy's only
like a couple months ago there I read it
and and you had not read the book no um
I kind of gave you an overview like sort
of what happened in it but um
interestingly I wasn't crazy about the
book like when I read it but this movie
I think sorry Stephen King but this
movie really improved upon the book
because okay this is directed by Mike
Flanagan who obviously did this isn't
the first Stephen King adaptation he did
he also did Gerald's game for Netflix
which was amazing even though a lot of
people thought that that book was not
film a bull because so much of it was
internal monologue he also obviously did
the amazing amazing haunting of Hill
House series and he did like hush
Occulus he did like all kind of like
really really good movies in series so
but I still have to say Mike Flanagan
you have some gigantic brass balls to
have attempted this in the first place
because basically what he had to do was
he's making
adaptation of the book dr. sleep which
is a sequel to The Shining however he's
also kind of making a sequel to Stanley
Kubrick's version of The Shining yeah
which differed significantly from
Stephen King's novel very famously but I
think he did a great job hiding yeah it
is tied it tied those two differences
together and blended it in if you've
seen the shining movie and read The
Shining book you watch this movie you
will see elements of both and how those
differences kind of get resolved I was
mostly thinking of like the boiler room
scenes yeah all right we're like oh okay
this is kind of going like the book but
it's a little bit different you'll just
see when you this is a real good way of
telling this story what another thing
that really got me with this story is
that you and McGregor is playing Danny
yeah once grown up well he also played
obi-wan Kenobi and this movie is very
much about the force too right along yes
The Shining is the force it's just a
different tale in a different setting
from a different time it's not in
another galaxy long time ago far far
this is now alright and in many ways
this is a lot like a story about I guess
you could say a gray Jedi or a fallen
Jedi going against sith because these
bad guys really they're [ __ ] basic
very similar these are they're like a
there's they all have a shine their
psychic and they're kind of like psychic
vampires it's like a vampire and then
but to have some of them have different
abilities to that you'll recognize from
other King books yeah other King stories
so they're kind of working as almost
like a witch's coven almost kind of like
a band of gipsies kinda gypsy
fortune-telling you know the main
villain kind of looks like a gypsy
fortune-teller to me Rosa Ferguson was
the actress that played one of the
Bergin's Rebecca Ferguson one of the
villains man she's [ __ ] great great
in this book she is great yeah and I
feel like a lot of like I didn't read
any reviews before we went and saw the
movie but I read something like
afterward before they recorded this and
every single one of them has called her
out because she's she's such a complex
villain it's like she's
clearly yeah super evil yeah in Star
Wars lore she would be a Sith Lord or
yes lady she showed some [ __ ]
weird-ass psychic abilities astral
projection
kind of like telepathy and at one time
she kind of showed some supernatural
strength yeah you know which is it's you
just got to see the movie and it's good
some people I've heard some complaints
saying that it's not scary I don't
really know where they're coming from I
saw it in IMAX yeah and the sound
effects and the sounds [ __ ] were
awesome in this when they go back to the
overlooked way it sounded in there I
kind of at first I was like they might
have overplayed their hand and the
shining was silent all the time in the
Overlook which kind of eerie they went
another way you know cuz you don't see
this you're not gonna see the Overlook
you remember I mean it's been abandoned
for a long time it but I have to say
like [ __ ] look cool the [ __ ]
production team because holy crap I mean
they really went all out in completely
and deliberately very meticulously
recreating the Overlook except many
years later then it's been like
abandoned because like an abandoned Hulk
yeah and it's like it looks great I mean
sort of really good job any of you
people ever been into an old abandoned
building that was big like that like
when you're a kid and you break into an
old abandoned hospital or something just
like that you know there's an Eaton
there's the powers off there's this
[ __ ] eerie feeling of being in a damn
cave or in a sunken ship or in something
or in a ghost ship out on the ocean you
get that kind of impression when they
went into the Overlook the way it showed
and snow at night and they walk in and
the sounds of the wind [ __ ] blowing
through there
it just was and it's sucking haunted you
know you saw that movie yeah but I mean
I really really like you weigh that Mike
Flanagan like I said he really balanced
you know it the first two acts are very
much like an adaptation of the book a
couple things are different like not a
huge amount there was a couple like plot
you know cuz the book is very long I
think it's like 600 pages and it's kind
of rambling it's like a road trip kind
of movie there's
a couple of subplots that were taken out
which weren't all that important so I
think he did a good job like just you
know kind of getting it down to like a
concise kind of like plot thing I mean
this movie is still pretty long it's two
and a half hours yeah I doesn't feel
long it really does it I mean like I
said it's such a sprawling novel that I
obviously loved it the audience loved it
nobody got bored or anything yeah it's
not boring I didn't think there wasn't
even any really any slow spots in it I
didn't think I know I didn't think there
was I mean every single thing that
happened happened for a purpose yeah
there's always weird psychic phenomena
that's and pretty much everything its
dramatized it's definitely dramatized
this is a [ __ ] movie but every
psychic phenomenon that is portrayed in
this movie is one that has been reported
yeah if they're reported in real
parasite parapsychology cases or
reported given to us through legend yeah
you'll see what I'm talking about you
know some of its kind of legendary you
know I mean it may be something like
that exists it's been rumored to exist
that kind of [ __ ] which I just like that
I like the plausibility even though you
know the there's a lot of show buzz in
in terms of you know the the
presentation it's a movie you know but
there's still a lot of plausibility in
certain effects that you see yeah it's
pretty cool but yeah I mean this I I was
like hoping that this would be good but
I was like well I'm trying to temper my
expectations like something like this
could go drastically drastically wrong
because like I said it's such an
ambitious the project the trailers did
not do justice they really didn't it's
live in that trailer I was gone that
looks almost like something made for TV
I saw this thing I said look all that
good no the movies very different than
the trailer I'm going back and watch
that trailer and went yeah that trailers
not really it yeah yeah there's not what
that movies like maybe that's what it
was maybe like the trailer was fine but
it's like it was a little underwhelming
yeah so I so I was kind of trying to
think well you know I'm not gonna be sad
if it's not good or anything like that
but then I was like surprised to like
how much better and actually like I said
I liked this better than the book which
I don't say liked it much better than I
thought I was gonna like I liked it I
bought shoes
better than it I think I like it better
than Joker even though it's of job's a
bold statement even the Joker is a very
different kind of movie yeah I enjoyed
this better than more than Joey Joker
yeah I liked Joker I had Joker in the
number one position for the movie of the
year I think I think this one took its
place I think I'm gonna put yogurt
number two even though I'm pretty sure
Joker is gonna kick this movie's ass at
the box office
probably but me personally for my own
personal reasons you don't mean me
because that is like your kind of thing
yeah because the madethe mountain and
everything that happened to me you know
and [ __ ] growing up watching the
shiny I'm gonna put this one in number
one yeah this is definitely something
that's better than it - better than you
I like this a lot better than I liked it
chapter - yeah I like this a lot better
it might have been slightly better than
the first one I think it was um and I
have to say - one there's like a scene
in the middle of this like I said it has
some differences from the book not a
huge amount but they had to like finagle
some things because he was trying to
match it up with Kubrick's film as well
so it would kind of Alton go together
there's one scene in the middle of this
of like a particular character getting
murdered and that was pretty disturbing
yeah it's supposed to be though yeah
here's another thing I heard complaints
you see windy torrents and you see Jack
Torrance they're not played by of course
well obviously because and they didn't
use any CG to fake him or anything
they're played by other actors I think
they did a great job I think I said oh
they should have CGI - I don't think it
should have I don't I don't like when
they do that they had a good Wendy yeah
that sounded just like and that was you
know that was that was I don't think you
saw but that was actually Alex s oh she
was in starry eyes which was one of my
very favorite horror movies from the
last few years yeah so she played Wendy
and Jack comes back and that was and
it's real hard to [ __ ] beat Jack
Nicholson in that character it's very
hard and he didn't do an impression
didn't do a Jack Nicholson impression
which I'm gonna give him credit for that
because doing a Jack NuSkin Nicholson
impression would have [ __ ] that up
yeah he just went in there and did his
own interpretation of Jack and it's
pretty damn close and in the in a way
like here's what I here's what I was
thinking because when I saw that kind of
pivotal scene like in the Overlook where
that character is there I was thinking
to myself you know Danny was only five
when his father died he would really
don't really remember what he looked
like or what and and also you have to
think too that this version of Jack
Torrance is the hotel reflecting that
character back to Danny
yeah don't spoil which I which I'm just
saying that you know in in the shining
that was the same thing that happened
with Grady like you're a different name
and he said oh I don't know what you're
talking about it kind of split is it
kind of planned they all blend into one
it's like yes you're still kind of that
person but not really because you're
kind of becoming integrated with like
the hotel then there's another there's
another aspect of you know in Star Wars
tight Lord and mythology sometimes the
good guys have to confront evil in an
evil place kind of like Luke going on
Dagobah going down into the old sit
temple to have a vision you know where
he sees Vader in [ __ ] in a way this kind
of goes along that same theme of having
to go to an evil place to confront evil
and that's what all this going to the
Overlook it was really kind of all about
you know but which I think that just
kind of fit into that whole motif of
psychic warrior I like that [ __ ] you
know which like I said you know and I
was saying to this this you last night
in the car I was like you know the the
final whole cop final third the you know
the final confrontation which happens at
the Overlook and stuff like that I was
thinking in the book I was like you know
obviously because in Stephen King's book
The Shining the Overlook got blown up at
the end of the book so you know but in
Kubrick's movie like obviously was still
there so they had to kind of reconcile
that and I like the way they did that so
I was thinking to myself I was like well
in the book dr. sleep I was like where
did they have the final confrontation I
thought I thought it was just a random
field it wasn't it was actually the
field where the Overlook used to be so
they did actually ties yeah because I
was sitting I couldn't remember like I
was just like I thought it was just some
random field and I couldn't remember
that it was worth it I used to be but
yeah so but they did reconcile that
really well
like I said if you like on
Hill House if you like Gerald's game I
don't see any reason why he wouldn't
like this it's a it's an amazing movie
The Shining um he did yeah he did a
really good job like like I said it's
not Kubrick Ian's in the way the first
movie is but it has enough of that feel
to it that he did do some stuff with
music and shots and but he's not like
he's not trying it's not like a pastiche
of it no he's not trying to ape Kubrick
because he's got his own style right I
mean you know I mean his style is very
much all over the he throws some of that
Kubrick back at you in certain points to
get you to remember yeah remember that
this remember this set II remember that
said it yeah you know which makes sense
because like I said this is a sequel and
these are characters that you know many
years and this is Danny's memories of
you know this place that caused him so
much trauma as a kid so obviously you're
gonna see some callbacks to that but you
know what I mean it's like I said I have
to say this is easily one of the you
know one of the best horror movies of
the year one of the best Stephen King
adaptations probably ever so far I think
it's the best movie of the year really
yep we've seen a lot of really good
movies and I put and I put Joker right
underneath it I mean we saw this we saw
a parasite we saw Joker we said the
lighthouse was like there was a lot of
really good movies oh sure you guys I'm
gonna put this in above Joker just
because the content yeah because you
like this yeah thank you I still like
Joker a little bit better I think but I
don't know they're both they're both oh
okay they're on par they're different
stories they're different stories it's
hard to compare them what they're to
bring it to the table is both different
I I prefer I liked them both I think I
like this a little bit more yeah like I
said enjoyed this one yeah I want to see
it ever sin again yeah I mean I would
like to see it again too because like I
said I'm sure there was a lot of [ __ ] I
missed out on you know what I found out
that you know there's a scene where like
the one kid baseball boy it was played
by the kid from good boys yeah there was
a scene where he was at the baseball
game you know and the guy was talking to
the other guy and the stands like about
how he always knows that you know where
the ball is like he can read the
pitchers - stuff do you know that the
kid's dad was played by Danny Lloyd
Danny
shining and I didn't even realize that
until I looked it up later I'm like yeah
[ __ ] now a lot of people you know might
say well this isn't the original book
and it's not you know
the shining movie wasn't here a lot of
the really good [ __ ] this is going all
the way back to the original Star Wars
trilogy was him it was a group effort
you had an idea man and then other guys
kind of whittled it away and made it
into something that is is fantastic and
then you have Lucas doing the prequels
where it's basically just him and
they're not quite as good as those
original one so like you know Empire
Strikes Back and stuff and King is like
that a little bit he's a real good idea
man he's a good writer I like some of
these short stories if you're just
reading a short story by me oh yeah
that's good but adapting that [ __ ] to
send him up you got to go with somebody
that really know cinema yeah and King is
not a cinema guy yeah he's just not you
know if you were to have King do the
shining his version of the shining he
did do you end up with the shining TV
series yeah that's what you likes more
than I liked it I really I liked it but
it is not that the shining from the
Kubrick good know the way to go if you
want to make a self-contained movie as
you do it the way Kubrick did it yeah if
you wanted to do a miniseries then you
could do it the way King did it for the
TV series but that does not make a good
movie it makes not a good depends on the
book the movies got to be within two and
a half hours and a lot of King stuff
doesn't really translate that well
constrained because internal internal
monologue characterization you know
stuff like that and that doesn't tend to
it's not very cinnamon and little
characters who are well described pop
out and do something for a short period
of time and story then they're gone and
then disappear yeah and they disappear
never to because they don't have time to
like play no can't do that in movies
which I which I think like I said that
was really good I think Mike Flanagan
did a good job like yes this is an
adaptation of dr. sleep the book but he
changed a few things he changed you know
[ __ ] they have and he changed some other
shed in the middle like it he took out a
couple subplots but like I said I think
he did a really good job paying homage
to Kubrick's film and as well as the
original book of The Shining and the
book of dr. sleep and he did a really
good job like putting them all together
into into a cohesive whole that still
had something larger to say without it
be
you know and like I said he just did a
really good job kind of condensing
everything down but not making it seem
like oh [ __ ] was happening too fast or
who is this person and then they just
disappeared like that didn't happen I
thought it it was very a masterful job
yeah it just came out really really good
Kubrick's Kubrick's The Shining was
[ __ ] panned at the time at the time
that it came out and people complained
that it wasn't scary they complained it
wasn't scary you didn't really make much
money overtime let's get the crap over
the time that's been become a classic I
think over time this movie will be
appreciated probably well yeah I think
they're gonna I think it's gonna make a
good money I think it'll kick the [ __ ]
out of the Terminator that's running
right now I'm convinced to that but I
think this will be a I think this will
probably make more than it yeah well I
don't know it made it a shit-ton but I
think this might make more than it but
maybe like I said I liked I definitely
like this better than it Jeff but over
time people are gonna play this and
right alongside with the shiny you watch
10 years from now they'll still yeah put
input in doctor sleep and then we'll see
both over yeah yeah there's that would
be really cool I'd like for that to
happen cuz it's a really really good
continuation like I said I like it
better than the book honestly yeah the
book doctor asleep yeah so definitely go
watch this is a must see yeah go check
it out
[Music]